think I think you're right I think you  should just I think they probably should  be disclosing it as well so if they  don't is it a crime  um  I don't know I don't know what to say  about that I haven't really got  an answer I don't think it I don't think  they should be done for fraud if I'm  honest I think that's a bit much but um  I feel like that's like the other option  is great for essay that you could so say  like say if I had a partner and I was  having unprotected sex with them  thinking I was in a committed  relationship but they was cheating  unprotected then then surely that should  be something as well because I'm only  having unprotected sex consensually  thinking it's just us two so if my  partner was having was cheating  unprotected or whatnot then surely that  could be under that as well so